what is the dirtiest job that you do
have it is there a dirtiest job that you
would say that you've done yes
well yeah I mean in season two I would
have answered it because we have done
about 60 by then but by the time you get
to 100 200 300 I mean you can't compare
sexing chickens it's with skull cleaning
which we did in Oklahoma with so glad
just dead cleaning you know you don't
want to dirty up a skull oh I see that
we're done here we're gonna make you
were making us a yeah that's good does
anybody ever actually watch no good so
yeah you can't I mean I remember in the
first season it's a job called lift pump
technician I think I rented that once
you would you in would wastewater
treatment most of its mechanized or
computerized these days but when all
this pump ruptures real men actually go
down into the lift pump chamber and it's
kind of a it's a beat the clock thing
that the pump is four tons and it sits
at the bottom of a five-story shaft and
when it ruptures the shaft continues to
fill with with [ __ ] you know because
people just keep flushing their toilets
and so alarms go off and men throw on
these woefully inadequate suits to send
a spiral staircase muscle their way
through
series fare tight doors and swim to the
ruptured pump and not a crane lowers a
cable and you tie it off and hang on and
they winch the whole thing straight up
there's that movie about the Russian
nuclear submarine and it was like u-571
that had the ruptured nuclear reactor
and now people had to go in yeah I would
rather do that yep I think yeah well
this was so bad at the end of the day I
always take the crew out for a beer just
to talk about what we did because it's
fun and we're always thirsty and share
that day we were all just covered you
know covered with other people's [ __ ]
and we're standing in a little
semicircle and now nobody's talking
we're all just looking at each other cuz
it just it's just horrifying and we're
just trying to process what we were
seeing and finally after about a minute
and a half quiet I said uh I'll see you
guys later
we all just walked away and we really
didn't talk for a couple days you know
it was just - it just took some time you
know we needed to be alone with the
reality of decompress a little it's
other people's crap in your see here's
the thing about smell yes here's the
thing about well badly but ultimately
you just as long as you're next to the
guy who does it every day you have to
was there a lot of gagging a lot of
gagging a fair amount of vomiting but
the thing about smelled that most
disturbed me was a guy we were doing a
crime scene clean-up
and the smell is just I mean it just
gets on your tongue it gets in your eyes
and he said Mike the thing about the
thing about smells is you got to
remember all outer is particulate that's
a really fun fact really I mean really
think about their you know because it
what really I mean if you just consider
a fart for a moment right as I do right
so the reason farts are so funny and
offensive at the same time is that to
smell a fart you have to it's not about
oh look I smell it here because I
sniffed it it's like no it went into
your nose yeah into mucous membrane's
three-year old factory senses into your
bloodstream and then ultimately into
your brain and that's when you realize
it as a heart I followed it everywhere
up until my brain
register that and that's terrible it's a
hell of a thing so you know if I fart
right now and you smell it remember it's
particulate please don't and a thing I
mean it's just it's a big thing to
contemplate that a gas which is really a
particle that was in my ass a second ago
is now in your brain why do we always
laugh about it then because if you don't
you we you would we well but and we
don't weep my friends not on this show